this is al jazeera adrian finnegan here
in doha
with a newshour with coverage of the
most intense
exchange of fire between israel and
palestinian armed groups
in years an israeli air strike has hit a
residential tower in gaza city
the army says that it informed residents
of hanadi tower to evacuate before it
was targeted
gaza's health ministry says that at
least 28 palestinians have been killed
across the strip in the past day
after the israeli airstrike on that
building
the military wing of hamas said that it
would
respond with a barrage of rockets which
it would targ
which would target tel aviv that appears
to be underway uh right now al jazeera's
harry fawcett
is uh live for us in uh southern israel
uh harry you're safe to talk to us now
yes that immediate barrage of iron dome
interceptors that we uh we just
uh saw and had to interrupt our live a
few minutes ago
uh is now over but uh just to bring you
up to date from what we've seen here it
was an exceptionally
large barrage of rocket fire coming
north
out of northern gaza heading north at
the same time as we were getting alerts
on our phones
of sirens going off in tel aviv and
indeed reports of explosions
in the tel aviv area hamas military wing
had warned
uh the israelis that there would be a
response they said that tel aviv would
see something even
more powerful than what happened to the
city the nearby city here
of ashkelon earlier in the day during
that period
hamas says that 137 rockets were fired
within five minutes
certainly uh there was a lot of rocket
fire that got through
two women were killed as homes were hit
buildings were hit now there seems to be
this
uh additional very large barrage heading
towards tel aviv and
of course it follows the destruction of
that large residential tower inside gaza
there had been warnings throughout the
day that if israel decided to
attack residential buildings uh where it
had said that it had already
uh attacked palestinian islamic jihad
fighters in one apartment building
this building is said to have housed a
hamas office of some kind
hamas had said that if israel carried
out such attacks
there would be a big escalatory response
so both sides
are stepping up what is now an extremely
dangerous situation
there is uh no indication of any efforts
towards de-escalation at this moment
harry stay with us just for a second uh
let me just
uh bring our uh viewer up to date with
uh
what newswires are saying right now the
reuters news agency reporting that at
least
one person has been wounded in a rocket
attack on tel aviv
uh that they're quoting the israeli
ambulance service
um hamas says that it has fired 130
rockets towards tel aviv in its
uh suburbs and israel has halted all
flights at tel aviv's ben gurion
airport amid that rocket fire uh
from gaza uh harry that earlier
uh barrage of 137 uh rockets as you say
managed to
uh to evade israel's iron dome
uh system at least some of the the
rockets fired from gaza had had got
through
with another 130 hamas saying that it's
fired within the last few minutes
i suppose it again it would be
inevitable that that some of them
uh would would reach their targets uh
towards tel aviv
yes i mean i suppose we should put one
caveat on that that we are relying on
hamas's own figures uh in in saying that
but yes the
the sheer volume of uh of ordnance
flying overhead a few minutes ago
uh even if it doesn't get up to that
level it was a very significant
coordinated
very large barrage all at once and so
there has been some analysis on the
israeli side
military analysts wondering if the sheer
swamping of the iron dome system by
so many targets all at once could have
caused
uh the the ability for hamas to get
through
uh those defenses to a greater extent
than than usual
um there have also been claims by hamas
that they've used a new
form of missile one that uh is fired at
a more
horizontal level trajectory and
therefore is harder to track
and hit also some reports of
malfunctioning
uh iron dome system uh around ashkelon
earlier in the day
uh however of course when we're talking
about the sheer
volume of weaponry that is being used at
the moment
uh i think israelis never really believe
that the iron dome is 100
fail-safe and indeed it has been shown
not to be in the past
however people have got used to lower
level escalations
being largely although not completely
dealt with by this
extremely successful system uh but if
there was a reminder needed that it
isn't 100
failsafe uh or foolproof uh this is
being given tonight in in pretty
dramatic fashion
and what happens uh to to ordinary
people there in israel when
something like this happens then the air
raid sirens go off
uh people pretty used to living with
with this sort of threat but where do
they where do they go what do they do
well a lot of homes in israel have uh
storerooms or bedrooms which
also double up as bomb shelters with
heavy steel doors
and uh and various other safety
mechanisms and
and architecture installed and so
a lot of people do head for those rooms
those safe rooms in their own houses
there are also bomb shelters uh at
liberal intervals in most israeli
neighborhoods as well we're very close
to
to one here next to a bus stop at this
junction
and yes some more more rockets now being
fired
from northern gaza at least one rocket
i've just seen in any case
um three i'm being told from behind the
camera that there are three more rockets
just being fired
and so in the instance of the two women
who were killed in ashkelon one of them
at least
uh was said to be living in a house
which didn't have its own shelter
it required a minute to run or so she
was an elderly woman
and when the rocket hit her house uh she
was killed in that attack
all right harry um
before we go back to to to gaza yes
sorry harry
you're about to say right now
i'm just being told that in central
israel uh in the
town of hollande uh reports of a direct
hit to a bus
do we know anything about casualties at
this stage we don't know
how many people were in that bus if
anybody was uh but that is the latest
that we're just getting through uh
on this this very significant it's an
empty bus we're just hearing well
okay some reports guessing is an empty
bus i apologize i just wanted to bring
you the very latest on that but this is
a
constantly moving situation and a very
major escalation in the danger
around what has already been a very
dangerous day all right harry many
thanks
uh indeed al jazeera is harry fawcett
they're live uh
in southern israel uh we want to go back
to to gaza but we're having trouble
uh connecting with our correspondent at
the moment
we'll try and get communications with
him
again in as soon as possible
in the meantime the arab league has been
holding an emergency meeting to discuss
the escalating violence uh jordan's
foreign minister
has told the virtual session that
israel's aggression and its violation of
international law
will only fuel the conflict and push it
to explosion
qatar's foreign minister who chaired the
session says the israeli bombing of gaza
is
a condemned and unacceptable criminal
attack
and the arab league's secretary general
ahmed abul
gate has asked the u.n security council
to act
over what he called the blatant
violation by israel
of international resolutions
the united nations has appealed uh for
all sides
uh to uh for restraint on all sides so
let's go
live now to the united nations al
jazeera's kristen salumi is there for us
what's the un saying kristen
well adrian in the last hour or two
we've had statements from the secretary
general
and from the president of the general
assembly but we're
still not getting any word from the
security council which did hold an
emergency meeting on monday but no
formal statements coming from them as of
yet
the president of the general assembly
vulcan bosqueer perhaps
issuing the strongest statements from
the united nations condemning the
attacks against civilians
and religious places including recent
airstrikes in gaza he called on
israel to abide by its obligations under
international law and he called on the
u.n to act immediately
to get israel to uphold those
obligations
and protect palestinians whom he said
are bearing the brunt
of the ongoing violence in in the
occupied territories and in israel
uh and he said that he's willing to call
a meeting if
other member states are willing to uh
ask for one
this uh was a statement that he released
on twitter
the secretary general for his part
issued a statement
expressing his grave concern about the
escalating violence as well
and sadness about the death of civilians
but he
stopped short of uh condemning
the uh attacks on gaza while he was very
quick to condemn
rocket attacks into israel he called
on uh israeli forces to issue
maximum or to use rather maximum
restraint have a listen to what he said
the secretary general is gravely
concerned by the serious escalations in
the occupied palestinian territory and
israel including the latest escalations
in gaza
which add to the heightened tensions and
violence in the ah in occupied east
jerusalem
he is deeply saddened to learn of the
increasingly large numbers of casualties
including
children from israeli airstrikes in gaza
and of israeli fatalities from rockets
launched from gaza
kristen uh realistically is there
anything that that the un
can do to to stop the violence
all power to act comes from the security
council and at this stage we cannot even
get the security council to agree on a
statement to the press about the
situation there this is
traditionally a very thorny issue for
the council we know that
russia norway and tunisia
yesterday suggested a statement calling
for
calm and an end to the violence there
this is still being discussed the united
states has said
that it does not want to do anything to
exacerbate the situation
suggesting that a statement might in
fact do that
exacerbate the situation so we are
essentially at an impasse in the
security council unless they can come to
some
agreement later on today but for now
strong words
from the president of the general
assembly condemnation of
uh attacks on israel from the secretary
general
uh and wait and see what happens with
the security council
kristen salumi there reporting live from
the united nations in new york for the
moment uh
kristen thank you you're looking at the
latest pictures
out of tel aviv this has all happened
within the
last few minutes uh the military wing of
hamas has said that it's fired over 130
rockets towards tel aviv
in response to an israeli airstrike that
had flattened a tower block
in the strip uh the al-qasam
brigade said that we are carrying out
our promise by launching a massive
rocket strike against tel aviv in its
suburbs with 130 rockets in response to
the
enemies targeting of residential towers
it said as a result at least one person
is reported to have been
wounded in a rocket attack uh on the tel
aviv
area
the national ambulance service reporting
that one person
critically wounded and as harry forsek
was telling us
it appears that a bus has been uh has
been hit
uh at lea in these airstrikes
a barrage of rockets we saw here on al
jazeera leaving
the gaza strip some of which were
intercepted by israel's
iron dome defense system but obviously
looking at these pictures now
from israeli television some of those
projectiles have gone through and have
reached their target let's bring in
uh al jazeera's harry fawcett uh once
again who's in
uh southern israel and harry you were
able to to watch those missiles
going basically overhead of you there
and their
attempted interception by iron dome
that's right yes those uh missiles fired
shortly before what at local time uh was
coming up to
nine o'clock and that was exactly when
the uh
warning had been that there was likely
to be a surprise in tel aviv that was
what uh hamas's military wing
was talking about and it was less than
an hour after the
israeli attack on that 13-story
residential building
inside gaza the hanadi building they had
issued warnings to the people who live
in that building the tens of families
who live in that building ahead of time
to evacuate it
and it was then brought down with at
least two strikes
hamas had said that attacks on
residential areas would be met
with an intensification and longer range
in terms of its rocket response then it
said that it would attack tel aviv and
it has made good
on that escalatory pledge just as israel
said that it was going to
increase the pace and the intensity of
its own
attacks so both sides are seemingly set
on an escalatory path right now and this
attack
on tel aviv it represents the most
serious such
breach of israeli defenses uh in the
main
big city of israel on the mediterranean
coast there
home to a very large population
and uh this does represent an extremely
dangerous
last hour in what was already the
biggest escalation we've seen since the
last war
in 2014. the u.s state department harry
says that the us is deeply concerned
about
the escalation between israel and
those launching rockets from gaza it
says that it seems some encouraging
steps
from both the israeli and palestinian
side
what would it take to end this violence
now to take the heat out of this at this
point
it's very difficult to see the heat
being taken out any time
soon i think a lot will depend on the
the casualty
numbers on the israeli and uh
gaza side we've just heard that um in
holland where
that bus was struck uh that there were
three
injuries there so i'm just going to ask
my colleague was that in that bus attack
or we don't know
uh we think perhaps not but yes so so
injuries
are already uh being counted uh if there
are greater
numbers of fatalities of course that
leads further to the escalatory
tendency of this whole situation uh the
reports we were getting out of gaza were
that egyptian attempts to mediate
had so far not been met with success uh
there were reports that they had been
trying to persuade
hamas in the first instance to dial down
the level of its rocket fire
and then try and convince israel to uh
to respond
however neither side apparently in the
mood to do
those things the build-up of tension has
been going on
for a month now since the beginning of
ramadan
we have one more day of ramadan on
wednesday before
the eid festival and this is the kind of
situation that's that eid will be marked
in the midst of uh it has been an
extraordinary
couple of weeks of rising simmering
tensions with the threat in the
background always
that it could spread to gaza in this way
and it has done so despite what perhaps
what the u.s
uh was talking about the decisions by
israel to
uh not allow jews onto the temple mount
as it's known to use
the al-aqsa mosque compound on monday to
disband or
change the route of the planned uh
nationalist march
through the old city which ended up not
happening if they were seeing those
concessions
uh in some way a lot of uh empty trucks
coming back having delivered military
hardware uh
to the gaza border if those moves would
have been seen as an attempt to
uh to try to tamp down the situation it
followed very shortly after those
terrible scenes we saw
on the al-aqsa mosque compound on monday
morning and so
uh already it seemed that the uh the
path had been set and hamas issued
that warning that it was going to attack
jerusalem
if uh there were not a uh a withdrawal
of israeli forces from the al-aqsa
mosque compound and from the
neighborhood
of shaykh i think those are conditions
they probably knew were not going to be
likely to be met and as soon as those
long-range missiles headed
in the direction of jerusalem on on
monday evening
we've been set on this path and the
decisions being made so far
only seems set to take us further along
it harry for the moment many thanks
salvation harry forsett there reporting
live from southern israel if you've just
joined us
uh the military wing of
hamas has said that it's fired over 130
rockets towards tel aviv
on tuesday evening in response to an
israeli air strike
that had destroyed a tower block
in the strip earlier uh
another well that looked like a pretty
big
missile it was different to to the ones
that
we saw leaving the gaza strip in that
barrage of rocket fire a little earlier
live pictures there from gaza let's
bring in al jazeera's
software alcalute who's in gaza
you probably i don't know you couldn't
see it from where you were safely but we
saw
uh what looked like a a pretty big
missile uh being launched out of
out of the gaza strip there
yes as we saw earlier even the sky of
gaza is flaming
rockets have been fired from gaza longer
range rockets have been fired from gaza
towards
ashkelon ashdod and tel aviv the cassam
brigades
claimed responsibility for the for the
attack in response
to the destruction of hanadi building uh
now
there are more rockets have been fired
which
looks like uh as if they were longer
range rockets
because they are flying higher than the
the short range
we just learned that the israelis have
warned also
that they will destroy another tower
which is just the one
next behind us the red one behind us and
that people have to evacuate
to evacuate the building this building
we know about
lots of media groups working there
including newspapers tvs and other media
groups
so far the case is that is even islamic
jihad joined
the kasam brigades and also said that
they have fired their rockets
towards tel aviv and this is still the
beginning as they said
um we are expecting more uh
more or wider range of uh violence of
escalation
we are expecting more buildings that
could be bring down like
hanadi one and as as we learned that
even the one
behind us also will be uh will be
destroyed
as as still there is no confirmation but
this is the news what we have received
now
uh we are still uh the night is still in
the beginning and
we are expecting that later on there
will be more rockets by
the palestinian fighting groups and
israelis which have
extended which have extended their bank
of targets
we are expecting them to hit more
residential areas and they even
some some voices say that they will move
to the next step which is targeting
senior commanders of the fighting groups
and could be also
one some of the political figures of uh
the the palestinian political groups
uh and southward we were talking to
harry forces earlier about what happens
to
israelis when the sirens go off and
there's incoming fire from gaza
what about the people of gaza
do they have anywhere to go any shelters
anywhere to take
shelter when israel is
attacking targets in the strip
yes i i heard my colleague harry when he
said that they were
going and into shelters but when the
rockets were fired from gaza in gaza
there are no shelters
the only thing that people can do is
just stay in their homes
that's why um when the israelis hit any
target
most of the casualties are civilian
because there there's no
nowhere to go no bankers no shelter no
is uh prepared for such uh such
exclusions or such escalation
so the only thing people can do is just
to stay home
and wait for the next target where and
how and who
except what uh for the moment many
thanks sapphire to al-qaeda
live for us in gaza city no doubt that
we'll be back with you uh in the next
few minutes uh southward i want to bring
in uh
al jazeera's senior political analyst
marwan bashara
who's been standing by uh since this all
began
uh and has been listening and watching
uh
to uh watching our coverage uh here
marwan
we knew this was gonna this was coming
wasn't it some kind of uh
retaliation here after israel struck
that residential building in gaza
yes absolutely and i was uh i was taken
a bit by
what i heard from our correspondents and
i think you know the fact that we have
uh and we are unique in that as al
jazeera having uh
uh two correspondents on both sides of
the
so-called border uh both in gaza and
israel that's important but i think
the the you know the important
observation we just heard
is that these are two very different
situations
uh israel is a modern prosperous strong
nuclear power state with the most
advanced
air force in the region and perhaps in
the world one of the most
and gaza is a big concentration camp
of refugees that's been that's been as
such for the past
50-plus years an impoverished camp
of refugees and whatever they have in
so-called
missile technology is basically homemade
or karaj made
type of archaic uh uh you know arms
and and and the more important
observation is the one about
shelters you know people in gaza two
more
two plus million of people uh that have
no shelters
no such thing exist so basically the
asymmetrical
nature of this conflict
if you want to call it that way between
israel and gaza
tonight is the most important aspect of
it
in the sense that there is no
two sides per se that two-sidedism
uh is is a fake news if you will
when describing what's going on in
israel and gaza
just look at the figures not just uh
this this
this conflict look at what happened 2014
2008 2006
and before that there's always this uh
disproportionately high casualties and
death and destruction in gaza
in comparison to the very low injury or
perhaps death in israel
of course in as far as we and hopefully
everyone else is concerned
any death is a very sad and tragic
development but clearly the price that
gaza
paid that palestinians in gaza pay is
always much higher and so i hope this
thing
stops because netanyahu's
cynical i would even say sadistic use
of israel's advanced weapons against
the mostly unsheltered people of gaza
will be will lead to a lot of mayhem and
destruction
but just like every other conflict that
you and i and everyone else covered over
the last few years and decades
we will go back to point zero in the
sense that
there is no military solution to this
kind of tension
to this kind of uh uh conflict if you
will
certainly not occupation certainly not
what is happening
in jerusalem speaking of uh prime
minister
netanyahu israel in political turmoil at
the moment i know from
from discussions we had uh in the
previous hours here on al jazeera
do you have your theories as to why this
escalation is happening right now
i think there's a good number of reasons
and i think
a good a good part of them fall in
mr netanyahu's lap uh you know we've
known him to be
he's widely known to be you know almost
a serial liar
and a skillful manipulator this is just
uh
you know the wide perception in israel
itself
and elsewhere and so now that he's in
desperate situation not that he is
on trial in israel on a number of
important corruption charges that
it's almost definite that he will end up
with in jail
like his predecessor a hood ulmer unless
he stays in power so he has been doing
everything possible
in order to stay in power including
going to
three three different elections within
two years it's almost unheard of
why in order to stay in power he is the
only obstacle why there is no coalition
government
in israel today after two years and
three elections
so what is what he has he been doing
he's been very busy
he's been very busy forming uniting
and allying with the most radical
fanatic israelis and these are the
jewish zionist party
that actually ended up with six seats in
the present israeli parliament they
are mr netanyahu's allies they are the
ones mr netanyahu has been covering for
as they have escalated the tensions in
east jerusalem
they are the ones behind much of the
tension that has been going on in east
jerusalem
for the last several weeks and in fact
months and years
those very radical fanatics think that
uh
that without them taking over fully and
evacuating the palestinians from the
city
there will be no peace and no jewish
state
so what we have here is now netanyahu is
encouraging these people to do
this sort of escalation east jerusalem
leading to
the response that we've seen on the part
of hamas and others saying look if
you're going to keep continue strangling
jerusalem
if you're going to continue besieging
asks our mosque we as we as the
palestinian leaders we're going to
retaliate
and hence netanyahu in fact jumped on
the occasion
because the last thing he wants is the
focus in jerusalem
he loves the fact that the focus can now
shift away from jerusalem from the
popular peaceful
resistance in jerusalem to that kind of
retaliation and counter relations
against
gaza that also allows him
to build or the kind of support within
israel for perhaps
a national emergency government he did
that before
by the way and he and i will also give
him the chance
to deny the the the comp the the the
competition within israel like
you know the uh the hatit party and the
lapids of the israeli political system
to
form a an alternative quality government
so i think
to a large degree prime minister
netanyahu
is using this unfolding tragedy
in order to remain in power whether he
succeeds or not of course is another
story but for the time being
this is the story the story is that why
now
why the escalation why the tragedy well
because there is this
one man that wants to maintain power
in the country and that is benjamin
netanyahu
mom for the moment many thanks stay with
us we'll be back with you a little later
our senior political analyst marwan
bashar are there
live in doha it's just after half past
the hour this is
al jazeera with continuing coverage
of the latest developments from gaza and
israel
hamas says that it's fired 130 more
rockets from gaza
towards tel aviv in israel the israeli
ambulance service says that one person
has been critically wounded
in a rocket attack there and that latest
barrage of rockets has forced
tel aviv ben-gurion airport
to suspend
all flights these are
the latest pictures from israel you're
looking at uh right now from the tel
aviv
area let's bring in uh william shabazz
who's a professor
of international law at middlesex
university in london on a former
chairperson of the commission of inquiry
on the 2014 gaza conflict he joins us
now live via skype
uh from london professor thank you uh
for being with us i know you've been
waiting for some time
uh before we we we've got to you um your
thoughts
on uh this conflict which uh
now appears to be spiraling into
something much bigger
well the the military side of it if we
have a sense of deja vu
we know that there are going to be huge
amounts of palestinian casualties
um great damage to the infrastructure
in gaza as your your
commentator said a few minutes ago this
is a very lopsided
uh military engagement but it all
has to go back to the spark that began
this
this latest phase in the conflict which
is the dispute
about east jerusalem and the attempts
one has
there the feeling that that the the
seizure of land from palestine
the creation of refugees palestinian
refugees
which goes back to the late 1940s is
unfinished business
still for the people in power in israel
and
so now so this is all about trying to
take
homes away from palestinians and moving
them out and the result of course
has been a great deal of violence in
jerusalem fury of the
palestinians who were terribly
frustrated and angered by all of this
and now this terrible military
escalation
we'll have to see when the smoke clears
how much of the laws of war have been
observed by both sides
but what we do know is that there's
going to be huge suffering among
innocent palestinians children
non-combatants as there has been in all
of the previous conflicts in gaza
you talk about responsibility for a lot
of what's happening lying with israel's
political leaders but to what extent
does
does it also lie with the the former
american administration the trump
administration uh
and what does the biden administration
have to do now
to be to be able to take the heat out of
this to
to be able to to help to solve the
situation
well just about a year ago the trump
administration
took a very dramatic step by innocent in
in effect breaking
with the position it hadn't had been
part of a fairly unanimous
view um around the world with the
exception of israel
that the the west bank and east
jerusalem were occupied territory
and it ultimately had to be restored to
palestinian control that this was a
temporary situation
and it was governed by the fourth geneva
convention which means
no settlements no transfer of settlers
into the occupied territory
and the trump administration broke with
that about a year ago
uh it was not followed by other
countries around the world
so that it was just this was trump's
theory about how to
um how to rearrange the chessboard
really
and the biden administration should go
back on all of that
they should set the clock back to where
the us position was
over a year ago what trump did was he
emboldened
netanyahu and he he emboldened the whole
idea
that more territory could be taken from
the palestinians that more palestinians
could be kicked out of their homes
deprived of their livelihood and the
part that at some point or another will
be
deemed sovereign territory of israel
will be expanded
you probably heard marwan saying a few
moments ago that
there is no military solution to th this
conflict
uh this conflict where does the u.n
stand in in all of this
um i mean it's its position has always
been
the two solution is is that given all
that we
that is currently going on uh the
politics of israel at the moment is that
still a viable solution i think it has
to be
i mean there's either if there's one
state
if there's one state then the
palestinians have to be treated
equally as they are in all modern
democracies
they have to be free of discrimination
they have to have freedom of movement
within the territory of a single state
israel certainly doesn't want that but
that's what they would have to do
the alternative is recognition of
palestinian self-determination and the
right for palestine to have
its own secure borders this is either
one
can bring peace actually either solution
but the um has been
faithful to the vision that goes back to
the 1940s of the two-state
solution and i think that's still widely
shared within
israel and palestine but if there is
a move as israel seems to be pushing for
what we call
one hegemonic state that will absorb
parts of the occupied territories
they cannot do that without full
recognition of all of the rights of
palestinians
within the entire territory and they
don't have that
what they have human rights watch said
it a few weeks ago
is an apartheid state like south africa
and we saw where that led it's just it's
not viable in the long run
regardless of military solutions and
we know that the south africans tried
military solutions
with the black population in south
africa too none of that worked
ultimately they had to recognize a
system of democracy
and equal rights and non-discrimination
for everybody
that has to be the way forward